money market funds are really just
open-ended mutual funds but instead of
investing in stocks they invest in
really safe loans and Theora gets really
safe bonds and t-bills
so here's let's say that this is the
asset side of our money market fund and
right over here is the equity side we'll
assume it has no liabilities and the
value the total value of this equity is
often referred to in mutual fund world
as the net asset value so if this was
the this was divided into a million
shares you would take the nav divide it
into a million shares and you would have
your net asset value per share now this
structure that I just drew here is true
for any mutual fund but when we're
talking about money market funds we're
actually talking about what they're
investing in here on this asset side so
on a money market mutual fund they'll
invest in things like Treasury bills
which are really just loans to the
federal government that will mature in a
year or less or that I guess you could
view it as the lender is going to get
paid back in a year or less or
commercial paper and commercial paper is
just another word for short-term debt to
really really really safe corporations
and banks so commercial paper and just
to be clear t-bills mature in one year
or less and commercial paper matures in
one to two hundred and seventy days so
the reason why it's called the money
market is because it's the short-term
debt you're lending to these safe
entities on a very short-term basis just
that they can meet there I guess you
could say their cash requirements or
their money requirements but in general
these type of mutual funds these money
market funds are considered to be super
duper duper safe because besides the
fact that these are safe people to lend
to you're also going to be getting your
money pretty soon and these are also
super liquid markets so for whatever
reason even if even if you can't wait
for the 30 days until that commercial
paper matures it's very likely that it's
a very liquid market and you could
probably sell that security and get a
good value for it so the general reason
why people invest in money market funds
is kind of an
turn ative to savings I can buy a share
of of one of these open-ended funds I'll
get a little bit of interest on it it'll
probably be better interest than I would
get in my savings or checking account
and it is at least from the point of
view of many many investors comparably
comparably safe